c'est à vous de dire ces actions
devaient ce marais bonne ou non je veux
témoigner dans la rue parce que je suis
un intellectuel et que je pense que la
liaison du peuple et des intellectuels
qui existait au 19e siècle
pas toujours mais qui a donné de très
bons résultats devraient être retrouvés
aujourd'hui il y à 50 ans que le peuple
les intellectuels sont séparées il faut
maintenant qu'ils ne fassent plus qu'un
non pas pour que les intellectuels donne
des conseils au peuple mais au contraire
pour que ces masses prennent une forme 9
et c'est pourquoi je vous dis nous ne
retrouverons certainement pourquoi avez
vous refusé de témoigner au procès cela
j'espère que mes témoignages ont été
nombreux jusqu'ici qui n'ont jamais et a
changé ma situation très particulière
je suis je devrais être le bio de moins
cinq ou six inculpation je le dis chaque
fois au juge jeudi c'est peut-être non
pas à bout de m'inculper mais vous
auriez en tenir compte et à libérer les
autres puisque il ya deux poids et deux
mesures
comme ce témoignage n'a jamais eu aucune
espèce de poids et comment tient pas
compte
eh bien j'ai trouvé qu'il valait mieux
témoigner ailleurs c'est à dire auprès
des gens qui sont victimes de la
violence
et s'ils ne peuvent comprendre si l'essm
a eu raison ou tort